In September 2021, the CDC
recommended Covid-19 booster shots,
an additional vaccine dose,
for the elderly
and those at high risk in the US.
That echoed the booster shot rollout
in places like the UK and Singapore.
But in November, the CDC announced
a new recommendation:
all adults could get a booster shot.
And that idea had been a contentious
question among scientists.
"I do believe that all of us are going
to need another shot at some point."
"It's much more of a gray area for
younger people, particularly under 50s."
"I don't think we should get hung up
on should, may...
just go out and get boosted."
"FDA's Dr. Marion Gruber and Dr. Phil Krause
say there's currently no need for boosters
for the general population."
Dr. Celine Gounder was one of those scientists.
She wasn’t convinced that we all
needed more shots.
Up until recently.
So, to help me figure out what’s going on
with boosters,
I called her up.
GOUNDER: I had not planned to get boosted,
and yesterday scheduled a third dose.
And that's really a decision that was made
based on the emergence of omicron.
To start us off, can you sort of just
walk us through
what the science of needing boosters is?
GOUNDER: When you get vaccinated
you're stimulatingdifferent branches
of your immune system.
You're stimulating B cells,
T cells, antibody levels.
Those antibody levels are what protect
you robustly against infection,
particularly soon after vaccination.
But those antibody levels wane.
What we saw from the data in Israel,
as well as other countries like the US, is
you saw a waning antibody levels
at six months after the second dose.
But Dr. Gounder emphasized that
charts like this shouldn’t alarm us.
GOUNDER: Once those antibodies fade
away, the B cells are still there.
B cells are these little factories
to make antibodies.
So when you get re-exposed
to the virus,
the B cells recognize the virus
and kick back into gear
and produce antibodies all over again.
You're not fully protected
against all infection,
but you still have very strong, very
long-lived memory B cell responses
that are still there to protect you from
severe disease, hospitalization, and death.
So if we still have that protection
from severe cases,
why do we need more
antibodies from a booster?
GOUNDER: There are certain groups in
which we do see a reduction in protection
against even some of those
more severe outcomes.
And those are specifically older people.
In addition, people who are highly
immunocompromised
also do benefit from getting
additional doses of vaccine.
That was the reasoning behind initially
limiting boosters to the vulnerable:
that while boosters for all adults in general
could help replenish antibodies
to prevent any infections,
they weren't necessary for
preventing severe cases,
which vaccines continue to do
effectively for most people.
But many scientists like Dr. Gounder
have changed their mind on that stance
based on the information available about the
omicron variant at the time of this video.
GOUNDER: Now that you've had the rise of
the omicron variant,
it's a different conversation
about boosters.
The concern about
the Omicron variant is that
our vaccines may not fully protect
against this variant,
which has more than 30 mutations
in the spike protein.
B cells that would have recognized
earlier strains of the virus
may not recognize omicron.
It has changed so much
that your memory immune responses
don't recognize it.
But that's a prediction based on
looking at the genetic sequence.
By giving additional doses
of vaccine,
you can override that
relative immune evasion.
It’s not clear yet whether or not we’ll
need a new vaccine for the new variant.
That was actually a question companies like
Pfizer had with the other variants, too.
So even though there are still
a lot of unknowns about omicron,
experts like Dr. Gounder say boosters
may be a good tool against it,
especially if it turns out to be as bad
as some fear.
So at what point after our first round
of vaccinations
should we get boosted?
GOUNDER: So you should wait six months
after your second dose of COVID vaccine,
if you got the Pfizer or Moderna vaccine,
before getting a boost,
and you should wait two months after getting
the Johnson & Johnson vaccine
before getting a boost.
To really get to peak antibody levels,
you really want to wait about two weeks.
So if you're, say, planning to go
visit family over the holidays,
I would recommend getting that
additional dose of vaccine,
that booster dose, about two weeks
prior to travel.
And that booster doesn’t have to be the
same one you originally got.
GOUNDER: The NIH conducted a study
looking at,
do you start with Johnson & Johnson,
Pfizer, or Moderna,
and then do you boost with Johnson & Johnson,
Pfizer, or Moderna?
The study found that
not only is mixing vaccines safe:
all combinations work.
In the US, if you got initial doses of
an mRNA vaccine,
you can get either one as a third shot.
But it’s recommended that if you got
Johnson & Johnson first,
it’s most effective to get boosted with
an mRNA vaccine.
Similarly, in countries like Germany and Korea,
most people who got AstraZeneca
will be offered an mRNA vaccine.
GOUNDER: There is some thought
that the different vaccine technologies
teach the immune system to recognize
the spike protein in slightly different ways,
and that as a result, the immune system,
you could say, remembers better.
Considering that the vaccines have been so
unequally distributed around the world,
should we be concerned about
the ethics of getting a third shot
when so many people haven’t
even had their first?
GOUNDER: I think we should be worried about
that at a policy level, at a macro level,
but whether you yourself as the individual
choose to get a booster dose or not
is really not going to have an impact
on global vaccine supply,
because those decisions
are being made far upstream
from you going into your local drugstore
and getting a vaccination.
As for whether we’ll all
need boosters for years:
it’s really too soon to tell.
It depends on how much Covid is spreading.
GOUNDER: Look, boosters are not going to
end the pandemic.
What is going to end the pandemic
is vaccinating people
who are not vaccinated.
Your risk of infection is proportional to
how much virus is circulating in the community.
Even if you've been boosted.
We still have a long way to go
to vaccinate the unvaccinated.
But Dr. Gounder also emphasized
that we can do two things at once:
we can continue to vaccinate the unvaccinated
while also strengthening the defenses
of the vaccinated.
GOUNDER: Boosters do provide another
layer of protection,
especially with the rise of the omicron variant.
I think there is broader consensus
now among doctors and scientists that
everyone 18 and up in the United States who
can get a booster should get a booster.
That boost won't last forever,
but it does buy you time.